for e
okay
folks in case you haven't picked up your
quiz
already it's still waiting up there for
you okay Derek why have you moved from
your usual
seat okay good no so if you if you get a
chance please pick up your quiz even if
you think it contains bad news because
not picking it up doesn't make the bad
news go
away and picking it up might give you a
chance of seeing if I've screwed up
because I do screw up when I grade 650
quizzes in a day and I get tired I might
miss something and as I said the mistake
you're going to find are always going to
be one one-sided which is you're going
to point out things I've missed that
should add to your points that's
perfectly okay I can live with that so
look through the template look and if
you feel especially in the I hate
multiple choice questions in general
because it is all or nothing there is no
partial credit even if your reasoning
was right till that very last step so if
you feel strongly about your answer I'm
willing to listen right so give me your
case for why you picked what you did
because you know if there's a reason
then I'll I'll you know I'll concede so
this is now my objective here is to not
screw you up this is not about getting
your lower score it's if you so if you
feel this there's a reason for your
answer bring it up so today yes go
ahead it'll be the only quiz that
contains multiple choice because on
corporate governance there's really no
numerical question I can ask you right
it's a one part of corporate Financial
but it's all fuzzy all the time so I
can't tell you give me a number for the
board of directors and that's part of
the reason corporate government is in
trouble is because they try to convert
that fuzzy stuff into a number and then
you get gaming
right so today we're going to complete
our discussion of cost of hurdle rates
and move into investment analysis so
let's see where we are we have a cost of
equity for a company so RI help me out
so if I have a company and ask you
what's my cost of equity
no give me the generic questions you
would start
with what businesses are you in so don't
ask what beta because in a sense then
you're playing into the game right what
businesses are you in because you ask a
company what's a beta they're going to
look it up in Bloomberg and say my Beta
is 1.1 so the question should always ask
about a company shouldn't be about a
number it should be about things you can
use to come up with the number we need
businesses because we use the businesses
to come up with a bait for a company the
rest is coming from the outside right
the risk free rate you don't ask a
company what's your risk free rate right
the risk free rate is the risk free rate
it depend on the currency you've chosen
the equity risk premium you'll have to
ask a company another second question
which
is where do you operate not what's your
Equity risk premium so avoid questions
where the company can give you an answer
and then you trap by the answer ask
questions that you can use to build up
to an equity risk P so you got a cost of
equity cost of debt far simpler
right what's your default risk and again
the company I have no idea but they do
because every time you go borrow money
from a bank the bank set sets it default
spread based on either a rating or their
own assessment so you got the cost of
debt and the weights we said should be
market value weights so if you're a
publicly traded company you need a
market value of equity and a market
value of debt which one's going to be
easier to get
it's a publicly traded company so what's
the market value Equity
th times number of shares right you
don't dance around this there's no is so
it's a what's called market cap so one
of the things you will struggle with
when you first enter Finance is some of
the terminology right the market cap for
a company is not the value of the
company it's the value of the equity in
the company so when people ask you what
the largest companies in the world in
terms of value we usually look at Market
yeah but we're really looking at just
the equity Side market cap is so that
should be easy what do we but for debt
we need a market value of debt right
when is that going to be observable in
the market what does the company have to
issue for debt to be to have a market
value it's got issue bonds that are
traded saying companies do but here's
the problem even companies that issue
bonds to raise debt like Disney they
might raise 70 75% or of their debt in
the form of bonds and you can get the
traded price but the remaining
25% comes from where what's the most
common way in which companies still
borrow money around the world it's not
from issuing bonds it's from going to a
bank and taking a bank loan and the prom
bank loans is you take them there's an
interest rate attached to it but after
that it's not traded so if I ask you
what's the market value of the bank loan
you took two years ago you throw up and
say I don't know I get a book value I
can tell you what I bought
and here in lies the Trap that many of
us know have to fall into which is to
get the market value of debt you realize
that for most companies a big chunk of
the debt is not traded and getting a
market value is therefore impossible
we'll see you know whether that
impossible is true so most Consultants
Bankers companies when it comes to cost
of capital will use market value of
equity they following the rules but when
it comes to debt instead of using market
value they will use Book value they're
using Book value not because it's the r
number but because the reasoning is in
most companies your book value of debt
is going to be roughly equal to the
market value it's not like Equity with
the stock price can take off and most of
the time that will not get you into
trouble but I'm going to give you a neat
little trick you can use to actually
take Book value of debt to convert to
market value of debt and it requires
actually going back to foundations and
thinking about foundations of finance
and thinking about how you you price a
bond Patrick help me out how would I
price a
bond so what how do how do I price a
bond what do I use to price a bond let's
say I come to you with a bond I have the
coupons and the face value and you say
how much should I pay for the bond
what's the process by which we price a
bond you can pass it off if you want
okay that's very quick pass it on toou
help me out how do I price a
bond no in other words you look at the
current market interest rate you
discount the coupons and the face value
and it's much simpler than valuing a
stock right the coupons are given the
face value is given the interest rate
captures the default risk so it's a
higher default risk you discount the
coupons in the face value back you got
the price of the bond I'm going to steal
that idea to convert Book value of debt
to market value of debt let me go back
to Disney I have a cost of equity and a
cost of debt for Disney I have the
market cap for Disney I need a market
value that and there's nothing on the
slide there so obviously you're looking
at a blank
screen I think it's lighting up I can
see it it takes a little while to
actually show up I think see
there you
go so here's what I'm going to do to
convert Book value of debt to market
value of debt I went to Disney's balance
sheet and on the balance sheet the
accounted report in this was 2013 just
the interest bearing debt the total
interest bearing debt on the balance
sheet at Disney was
14,288 Million each of you should be
able to find that for your company right
go down the balance sheet you're going
to see a debt number that's a book value
of debt
then I went to the income statement and
when you borrow money what are you going
to see in the income statement that
accompanies that debt that goes with the
debt interest expense and the interest
expense on the income statement was $
349 million everybody with me so far
I've got a book value of debt 14,288
million I've got an interest payment of
349 million hang in there in the balance
sheet still keep going down and in the
footnotes Disney reports when the debt
comes due
us companies usually reported more and
more companies globally are doing it so
this is how much de in year one year two
year three year four and I took a
weighted average of when the debt comes
to and the weighted average of the debt
was 7.92 years so let's see what we have
you have
14,288 million in Book value of debt 349
million in interest
expenses and a weighted average maturity
of 7.92 years I'm going to treat this as
if it was a gigantic coupon Bond the
coupon is going to be $349 million every
year for the next 7.92 years and at the
end of the 7.92
years I'm going to get the book value
back it's like the face value of the
bond and I discounted back at 3.75% if
that looks mildly familiar it's a
pre-tax cost of debt that I estimated
for Disney by taking the risk-free rate
and adding the default spread now terms
of sequencing you see why you cannot
compute the market value of debt till
you go through the cost of debt
calculation so do it after your cost of
debt calculation and you're discounting
the coupons in the face
value the 349 million is an annuity why
it's a coupon it's fixed for the next
7.92 years the 14,288 million is a
one-time number at the end of the 7.92
years I discount them back
today what I get as a present value is
13.03 billion
yes it could be so if your debt change
during the course of the year you might
want to check to see how much it changed
and the newest debt is going to be close
to current market value so it's nice if
you have recent debt issues actually so
you can check to see the change on a
year-to-year basis because otherwise the
interest expense might reflect a very
different level of debt than the debt
you see on the
books so let me pause right there my my
book value of debt is 14.3 billion
market value that I'm estimating is
about 13
billion why is my market value lower
than my book
value not
Tren go back to the pricing of the bond
when does a bond trade at below
par when the interest rate is higher
than the coupon rate right what you have
here is an interest rate of 3.75% but if
you take the interest expense and divide
by the book value of debt you get about
3% so you have a coupon rate less than
the market interest rate the market
value of the debt is going to be less
than now I've opened the door remember I
said most of the time using Book value
of debt is going to be okay now do you
see when using Market Book value of debt
is going to get you into trouble what
are the
circumstances where the book value and
market value are going to deviate the
most what causes the interest rate to
change significantly from the time you
borrowed to
now two things can cause it to change
let's see what the two
are 2021 what was the t- bond rate in
the US 1 and a half% at the end of 20202
the t- bond rate was
4% if you borrowed money in
2021 could be a triple B rate company
you could borrow two and a half to
3% just a year and a half later that
same debt is going to be about 20% less
valuable than what you see on the book
so one is if interest rates go up your
market value of debt will become lower
what's the other what's the other
component that goes into cost of debt
the default spread right can the default
spread for a company change dramatically
over a year and a half yeah if it gets
into distress and its rating goes from
double A down to single B the default
spread will widen that's a second
scenario where the market value of debt
and the book value of debt can
diverge so when you look at Book value
of debt and you say can I use it some of
the time much of the time you can get
away with it but times when interest
rates are Vol they're changing a lot the
market value of debt will be different
from the book value so it's a onetime
deal you're taking all of the debt
you're aggregating it treating it like a
coupon Bond and Computing a present
value any question to the mechanics so
what are the three things you need to do
this for your company you need Book
value of debt that should be a slam dunk
you need interest expenses that's in the
income statement you need the weighted
maturity of the debt now I one of the
things for those of you followed my my
Bloomberg description suggestions and
printed off pages one of those pages
actually has a weighted maturity for
your debt which they pull off the
footnotes so it saves you the trouble of
find finding that footnote so check that
out you know what the what that weighted
maturity is
yes all debt right I'm taking all of the
debt which means if you have a lot of
short-term debt what's going to happen
to your weighted
maturity it's going to be shorter and as
the maturity get shorter what's going to
happen to the difference between Book
value and market
value it's going to get smaller right
and that makes sense if you have a lot
of short-term debt it's not going to get
a big divver in Book value versus market
value so it kind of takes care of all
the things you think about in terms of
market value a lot of short-term debt
will lower the weighted maturity it make
the book value so if all you de is 6
months to a year my guess is this this
this equation is going to do very little
to change the book value the longer the
the the debt you have and the older it
is the bigger the effect is going to
be yeah
I'm sorry short de is
what that's a good question because they
just tell you during the next year this
is one of those things where in
corporate finance finessing it is not
probably not going to make much of a
difference so let's say use 0. five for
the F for your one and you AT3 instead
of 0.5 the effect on present value is
close to zero so that approximation I
can live with because again I'm not a
fixed income guy I just want to get a
cost of capital so I can move on so
getting even a rough approximation is
going to work European companies it gets
worse they actually will give you debt
du between years 1 and three three and
five five and 10 I don't know why they
do this and if that's the case just take
the midpoint of each one and just keep
moving okay yes that
number no see that's a problem Bloomberg
is I mean the Bloomberg just takes
traditional debt we'll talk about leases
always good to keep leases separate cuz
leases actually follow a very different
set of rules in terms of present value
and that's going to be the closing point
of how I get Disney's Market de so this
was 2013 it brought in all the interest
bearing debt short-term as well as
long-term into my debt number but there
was this one item that I hadn't captured
which is lease commitments we talked
about this briefly lease commitments
have always been debt but accounting has
fought treating them as debt for much of
its life
why God Only Knows somewhere 100 years
ago an accountant made the decision that
you would allow that you would classify
leases based on whether you owned an
asset at the end of a lease this became
the Big Driver so you weren't owning an
asset it was treated as an operating
lease was an operating lease it showed
up as an operating expense you didn't
have to show debt in the books great for
retailers restaurants companies with a
lot of lease
commitments but as I said it's always
been de it's a contractual commitment so
whenever I've computed cost of capital
I've always brought leases head and even
before 2019 I wasn't going to wait for
the accountants to come to their sense I
said I've got to convert lease
commitments to debt and let's see how
you do this companies were not required
to report leases as debt but in the
footnotes companies in the US have been
required to show you what their lease
commitments are for the next 5 years and
Beyond it's a foot it's a table so so
you look at this table These Are
Disney's lease commitments what are
these lease commitments for could be for
the bur Bank headquarters building it
could be part of the theme park it could
be a variety of things but basically the
way to read these lease commitments is
these are not expected lease payments
these are actual contracts they've
signed and how much money is during year
one year two year three year four year
five and Beyond year five they gave me a
lump sum the lump suum was basically
1784 million why a lump suum because
that's what accounting dis closure
required so I took the lease commitments
Beyond year five and I said they're not
paying 1784 million in year six I'm
going to spread it out over five years
and basically I had so now I have the
expected or the contractual lease
commitments for the next 10 years I've
got to convert into debt right how do I
convert the book value of coupons and
face value into debt I just discounted
back at the pre-tax cost to debt I do
the same thing here I discount the Le
commitment back at the
3.75% what I get as a present value is $
2.93
billion saying what does that tell me
the commitments I've signed essentially
are $2.9 billion in additional debt so
in 2013 if you ask me how much debt does
Disney have I'm going to take the 13
billion in market value of interest
bearing debt and on top of that I'm
going to put in the 2.9 billion giving
me a total debt of 15.96% billion from
this point on for the rest of the class
when I talk about Disney's dead in 2013
you're going to see
15.96% these lease commitments in 2019
both IFRS and gap finally came to their
census they said what leas is a debt
welcome to the party what took you so
long so starting in
2019 if you are a company governed by
FRS a gap you now have to show lease
debt on the balance sheet so if you take
Walmart anybody doing a
retailer if your sector is retailing you
look at retail companies Walmart Target
you're going to see a big debt number in
billions of dollars that's the present
value lease commitments accountants are
doing exactly what I did on the previous
page they're now showing it as debt
there's Ripple effects it affects your
operating income it it basically your
financials get redone but accounting
being accounting they can never do
something simply so when they did the
2019 lease rules first they had to leave
some Escape hatches cuz remember it's a
contractual commitment that's what r
Treat as debt so if you have flexibility
in that commitment enough flexibility to
get out of a lease they actually let you
not count that as debt the second is and
you can't blame the accountants alone
companies were lobbying for easier rules
so didn't have to show as much debt on
the balance sheet the end result is you
got this mangled accounting policy which
is not quite pure and one of the nice
things you can still do is you can
computer your own lease debt so if you
have a company you see lease debt and
you don't trust the accountants you can
always go to the contractual commitments
do what we did and replace that
accounting debt with them just a final
note this is lease debt we treat leases
are treated as debt because they're
contractual commitments right know I
know quite a few of you doing Netflix I
can see that show up on on
the with Netflix there is an analogous
commitment that is not nothing to do
with leases it's got to do with content
you know what I'm talking about you get
on Netflix you can watch content that's
made by Netflix but you can also watch
content made by others right for a long
time they were showing The Avengers
movies Seinfeld episodes in fact the
highest rated shows on Netflix are often
shows made by some suits for a long time
was most watch show in suits is not a
Netflix show saying how the heck is
Netflix allowed to carry suits and make
it the because they pay for the right to
carry suits and it's a contractual
commitment so you go to Netflix balance
sheet look at the footnotes in addition
to Lee commitments they have content
commitments in year one year two year
three and if you're looking at Netflix
as a company trying to compute the cost
of capital you'd include that their Mets
have a lot more debt in their balance
sheet today than they did a year ago why
what's a contractual commitment that's
on the balance that that they have now
and a year ago 765 million to One S
right over 10 years is it a contractual
commitment one clearly thinks
so right he's probably already spending
money that he's going to get in the next
10 years it is a contractual
commitment and Steve Cohen might have
good reasons for signing one soda and
I'm not saying this is going to break
the Mets as a Yankee fan let me have my
brief moment there it's not going to
break the Mets but if you look at the
debt ratio for the Mets the present
value of 765 million over 10 years at a
pre-tax cost of debt for the Mets last
year two years ago actually the Mets
invited me into do a corporate finance
session for their management was was at
the 72 building because Steve owns both
I guess it's a fun
session because we went through a cost
of capital for the Mets and I talked
about contractual commitments I hope
they invite me back again you know
because I did wear a Yankee hat and that
might have gotten in the way of the the
message being delivered but when you
sign big contractual commitments you're
effectively borrowing money any
questions on debt then
yes
yeah
yeah no no it's not the cost of capital
it's a pre- tax cost of debt you
remember with the Disney the way we got
it we started with the risk free rate
2.75% then and then we looked up the
rating for Disney single a so that's why
that part of the process which we did
last session has to come before you do
this because without a pre-tax cost of
debt you're upper creek without a paddle
you have really no way of converting
numbers into
de
yes yeah but yeah and and how do you
reflect that let's say have a contract
for Revenue when you value The Firm what
do we do we take the present value it
right I mean so it it doesn't enter the
debt ratio calculation on the asset side
how you fund the contract will show up
on the data so that's exactly what we do
in valuation right we take cash flows we
discount them back we take the present
value incidentally the one SoDo contract
is worth 620 million or something you
discount the 765 million back the shyon
contract is worth only 400 million
is uh Scott boras Shy's agent as well I
don't know who his agent is but shy
should fire his agent he got 700 million
plus but because it's all back ended I
think 680 million is not for know 8
years or 10 years from now the present
value is 400 million and that's Now
setting the the the the bottom line for
Superstars they all want show you a tiny
plus you're trapping other teams into
paying far more if this is deliberate on
the part of Dodgers it's a gen move
because everybody else pays 750 million
it's a present value of 600 million
they're paying 700 plus million and
actually it's costing them only 400
million so now I'm ready to compute my
cost to cap for
Disney the risk free rate so this is the
culmination of 100 slides every number
here you can go back and check it my
risk free rate is the T bond rate why am
I using the t-bond rate because I'm
doing my estimates I chose to do my my
estimates in us dollarss it's not
because Disney is a US company I could
do it in dollars or Euros here have
chosen dollars that's a 10year t- bond
the 1.13 I've left it oddly precise is
the bottom up beta for Disney which I
got by breaking them down into five
businesses and taking a weighted average
the equity risk premium of 5.76%
reflects where Disney gets its revenues
82% from the US 18% from the rest of the
world there's my 8.52% cost of equiping
for the cost of debt I start with the
2.75% and I added a fall spread of 1%
based on Disney's rating the S&P rating
of single a if I didn't have the rating
I'd use a synthetic rating I multiply by
one minus a marginal tax rate which in
2013 was skyh high
36.1% my after tax cost of debt is
2.4% for the market value of equity I
use the share price times number of
shares I get a market value of equity of
121.9 billion for the market value of
debt and this is the lead up to what we
did today there's a market value of
interest bearing debt plus the present
value of lease is
15.96% equity 11.6% debt take a weighted
average cost of capital is
7.81% basically this is the the hurdle
rate for Disney as a company but as we
saw earlier that's not the hurdle rate I
would use an individual projects because
it depends on whether the project is a
movie Project a theme park project so I
completed that table I started when I
started with the bottom of betas I broke
dis knee down into businesses now I have
a cost of equity that came from our
previous bottom of betas the cost of
debt is the same for all the divisions
why is that
because Disney's divisions don't borrow
money Disney the company borrows money
are there exceptions of the rule G used
to have two cost of debt one for GE and
one for GE Capital because GE Capital
borrowed its own money if you have a
division that carries its own debt and
has its own rating and its own cost of
debt you would see difference in cost of
debt that's not the case for Disney so
what you see in the last column is the
differences in cost of capital now if
you came to me with a movie Project
what's your hurdle rate the hurdle rate
I would be using would be
8.63% reflecting the mix of debt and
equity and the cost in each of those now
already saying how can you have two
hurdle rates because earlier we talked
about the cost of equity is hurdle rate
I'll talk about when we use each there
is a place for each and you can't mix
and match decide this is a lower number
I'll take the lower number there is a
reason why you might use one over the
other with V where I done the cost of
equity by division in dollar terms I
complet completed the process and
computed the cost of capital for Val and
again I assume the same cost of debt for
every part of Val because Val as a
company borrows for all of its
divisions there's my cost of capital in
dollars by now you know how to convert
dollars into r or pesos or whatever else
you want to do just a differential
inflation I've got a cost to Capital by
business so I want to take a brief
moment and talk about how we have these
two different hurdle rates cost of
equity and cost capital and why you
might do those know why you might do
both calculations but you can end up
using only one but let me also complete
my cost of capital for my other
companies for tart Motors remember I
chose my cost of equity I chose rupees
as my currency so my cost of debt has to
be in the same
currency weights are about 70% Equity
30% debt and as we go through you'll
already start to notice that the debt
ratios are different for Disney for Val
for Buu each has chosen a different debt
ratio that's a question we're going to
come back to later in the class why do
different companies use different mixes
of debt and equity and is the mix they
using the right mix so have a cost of
capital in rupees a cost of capital in
in Yuan and finally for bookscape I
computed two cost of capital why because
remember we talked about the total beta
idea which if you're not Diversified you
see more risk in the company the cost of
capital I will get for for for bookscape
using a total beta is is 10.3% why
because my cost of equity is much higher
but if I do the same cost of cap from
the perspective of a diversified
investor looking at this bookstore the
cost of capital is only 6.3% that's the
advantage that borders has over
bookscape when they compete
head-to-head so cost of equity is your
cost of raising money from Equity
investors your cost of capital is your
cost of funding your entire business
with both debt and equity
so I know I keep harassing you about the
project but the best way this will get
nailed down is for you to do this for
your company no you can follow the
template that I did for Disney but
basically take it a step at a time come
out the cost of equity cost debt do
market value weights come up with the
cost of capital and just for yourself do
Book value weights and see what you get
as cost of capital because the next time
an accountant says I'm just being
conservative I want to hit them with
numbers and say this is what my cost of
capital looks like in Market value terms
this is what it looks like in Book value
terms any questions about the mechanics
of cost of equity cost of capital the
intuition so you got two numbers here
cost of equity cost of capital which
one's going to be higher for every
company cost of equ is going to be
higher unless you have a company with no
debt where the two will be roughly the
same so you take an Nidia you take a
meta the cost of equity is very close to
cost of capital but you have two
different numbers and you're saying
they're both hurdle rates you're saying
how can that be I'm going to lay the
principle and for the moment it sound
abstract but in the next section we're
going to put Flesh on this in on this
proposition if your Computing returns to
equity investors cash flows to equity
investors you're the equity investor the
hurdle rate you should be using is the
cost of
equity if you're measuring returns to
the entire company cash flows before
debt payments to all claim orders the
hurdle rate you should be using is the
cost of capital you tell me how you
compute returns or cash flows I'm going
to hand you only one of the hurdle rates
because only one of the hurdle rates
will make sense for the moment if you
have no idea what I'm talking about
we'll come back and use an actual
project so you can see these play
out so it took us a while to get there
almost half you know a third more than a
third of the way through the class but
you got one box nailed down the hurdle
rate for a project should reflect that
riskiness
of the project you're taken how do we
measure that with beta risk you cannot
diversify or default risk for thatb and
should reflect the mix of debt and
Equity used to fund it that's so the
weights you go into the cost of
capital let's talk about the other half
of the investment principle we got the
hurdle rate but to me decide whether a
project is a good project or a bad
project an investment is a good or a bad
investment you need an accounting return
return and I'm going to use one of my
favorite movies to bring home the theme
what's going to drive how we think about
returns in finance how many of you have
seen Jerry mire great movie right I
think it's Cuba Gooding who actually UTS
these
words it's about a
contract finally he says show me the
money notice what he didn't say he said
show me the operating income show me the
earnings per share said show me the
money cash cash out I'm going to start
this session by talking about why we
look at cash flows when we measure
returns how to bring in when the cash
flows happen because obviously we'd
rather get the cash flows now than later
one Soo is in a much better shape
financially than Shani they're all
they're both in really good places so
don't feel sorry for either one of them
because one sort is going to get his
cash flows
earlier and we're going to talk about
side effects because people often when
they talk about a project often talk
about other stuff Synergy strategic
considerations all that stuff I'm going
to try to bring into the returns so
let's
start with earnings versus cash flows
and why we kind of put our trust in cash
flows so I'm going to test you in your
accounting McKenry you're going to help
me out here in in businesses we have a
cruel Accounting in fact if you're a
publicly trated company have to do a
cruel accounting people talk about what
does AC cruel accounting actually mean
what does it you
know
okay you know not even cash flow so when
you make a transaction let's say you
sell something on December 29th you have
to show it as revenues this year even
though you might not have been paid for
it right and if you use stuff to make
what you sell you have to show it as
cost even though you might not have paid
for it I know it sounds
mysterious but when you sell something
on December 29th and you haven't been
paid for it what do you have to show on
your balance sheet reflect
that and you haven't been paid for
something yeah on the library side what
will it show up as a liability or an
asset somebody owes you money right so
is it's an asset so it should be a
receivable and if you owe other people
it's a liability it'll be payables
working capital is the residue of a
accounting if you did cash accounting
you wouldn't need working capital what's
cash accounting you record transactions
as you get paid so you're a plumber you
do a job if you get paid you show this
revenues if the person hasn't paid you
you don't show this revenues and if
you're a really small business you can
do cash accounting cash in cash out it's
actually a much more honest way of doing
accounting because it's not about
transactions did I get paid did I pay
somebody but with regular businesses
companies you have to do cor accounting
the second is accounting does have this
fixation of classifying expenses into
operating expenses Capital expenses and
financing
expenses Constantine help me out here
help me Define the three expenses what
goes in the operating expense box
let's I mean but it's not just that you
pay but the benefits are only in the
current year basically labor materials
now operating expenses our expenses is
so so cost of good sold if you have to
make something it goes into operating
expenses if you have sgna marketing
expense goes into operating expenses if
it's just for this year expenses that
create benefits for only the current
year going to the operating expense box
what goes in the capital expense box
expenses that create benefits over for
many years land building equipment
machinery at least the accountants
that's tangible fix but you can be much
broader
any and in the financing expense box you
put an expenses associated with the use
anything that's not Equity primarily
debt which is means most of the time
there's only one expense in that box
which
is interest expense he's saying why do
they bother because everything has its
place the accounting world is a very
orderly world in fact Kelly because
she's an you're an accountant right
Kelly you're going to help me out here
so you have revenues right where do
operating expenses go in your financial
statements right below revenues to get
to operating income where do Capital
expenses go
Kelly they go into the balance sheet as
an asset and in subsequent periods you
depreciate it or amortize it it'll show
up as part of your which kind of a
smooth D and financing expenses go below
the operating income line to get a net
income it's nice orderly word you've
created but you can already see why what
you report as accounting earnings might
have nothing to do with cash flows in
fact you ever given the accounting
earnings for a project or a company to
get to cash flow only three adjustments
only three not 15 not 27 three
adjustments you need to make first you
add back depreciation and amortization
in France why am I doing
that it's not a cash expense right if
you're if any of you writing checks out
to Mr
depreciation my name is close enough I
will change it collect the depreciation
checks it's not an it's not a cash
expense it's an accounting expense so
I'm adding it
back to get to cash flows then I
subtract Capital expenditures why do I
do
that even the accountant told me it was
not an expense but when I bought that
land did I have to pay for the
land yeah I can't tell the guy look you
know my accountant told me it's not
really an expense I'm not paying you
you're not going to get the land Capital
expenses are Cash Out flows no M no
matter what the accountant tells you
about those expenses so I'm going to
subtract out Capital expenses and then
I'm going to subtract the change in
working capital people do who do
valuation this shows up as a line item
they ask them why are you doing it they
have no idea but now you can tell me why
right what do I do when I subtract the
change in working
capital remember M McKenry described
know doing a transaction December 29th
giving me ac cruel income change in
working capital takes my cruel income
and makes it into a cash income that's
why we do it add depreciation subtract
cap subtract change in working capital
I've gone from earnings to cash flows
let's pause right there and let's think
about what might cause the numbers to be
different let's see have a company
positive
earnings Can it have negative cash flows
Derek what is what is the company what
is the company doing that can make
earnings into negative cash flows think
of the three adjustments the answer is
not high capex alone most companies High
capex what else are you going to see
high depreciation it's not high capex
per se but High capex relative to
depreciation if you're a mature company
with a lot of capex what you're going to
see is both numbers are high but if
you're you're a growing company your
capex will be higher than depreciation
because the depreciation reflects what
you spent 2 3 four years ago much
smaller number so big net
capex or you could be a very working
capital driven business retailer who
gives a lot of credit in which case you
can have net income that's positive but
because the change in working capital is
so large you can end up with negative
cash
flows and when the two are different or
can the reverse also be true can you
have a company low or negative earnings
with large positive cash
flows in fact if you're a privately
owned business in Asia Latin America you
know what your endgame is to keep
reporting
losses why because that saves you taxes
and walk away with large everybody
thinks you're a loser but you deposit $5
million in the bank every year it's okay
I'll take the
label but you can have negative earnings
and positive cash flows
and when the two are different in
finance we're absolutely
categorical we trust the cash flows so
I'm going to start with that as to why
in account in in finance we're so
focused on throwing away all the work
IFRS and GAP did to get to an earnings
we're reversing it to get to a cash flow
you cannot spend
earnings try where's the nearest
Starbucks now is one on Broadway still
right that that one is such a long line
you will never the time value of your
money will just melt away while go to
the Broadway one I think there's one
still on
Broadway walk in and
order grande caramel machiato why am I
picking something specific that's the
only thing I order at Starbucks I know
the price or let me take that back
Starbucks now is different prices based
on location do you know that check the
price next time you do your online
ordering check what it is on Broadway
Check what it is across the street let's
say it's
$6 you get an extra shot $675 or 7 or
whatever it works out to get to the
front of the line assum you're not
ordering online because this requires
that you actually be in
line and offer to pay the cashier with
earnings I don't know how this would
work say look I'm going through an MBA
program I think it'll substantially
increase my earnings capacity can I pay
with $7 in earnings this is almost as
bad as asking can I pay with $7 in
Bitcoin right the GU is going to say
that's nice but I need to see some cash
or venmo or put your phone down there
you can't pay with earnings earnings is
just a mythical number the accounting is
presenting so you cannot spend earnings
and if you really are tempted to go with
accounting earnings I have two words for
you Winston
groom no idea what I'm talking about
right any of you heard of Winston groom
he wrote A Few
books most of which were obscure but one
of the books he read in the 1980s
somebody at a movie studio I think it
was Paramount read the book and said
this would make a neat movie the name of
the book was Forest
Gump they made the movie and actually
the first approached Winston and said
would you like us to make a movie and
it's very flat it somebody wants to make
a movie out of his book no this isn't
Stephen King where every book becomes
three movies
and they offer him a contract and he
takes a look at the contract and it
looks pretty
good it entitles him to
5% of the accounting profits on this
movie mistake number
one and it keeps going it says defined
using Studio Accounting Standards
mistake number
two any signs mistake number
three movie gets made that Tom Hanks
stars in it one of the highest grossing
movies of its time wins a couple of
Academy
Awards and poor Winston's at home
waiting for the check and it doesn't
come and it doesn't come he's finally
convinced they must have lost my address
so he calls pair amount and he says
where's my
5% they said 5% of what the money you're
making on this movie they said we're
losing tons on this movie how can you be
losing tons if you got gate receipts of
200 million plus they say you can come
in and look at our books and he goes and
looks at the books and reports a loss of
150 million in the movies he looks down
the line items and he sees a line item
for $175 million as an expense he says
what is that so that's a provision for
what future bad
movies Studio Accounting Standards rears
its ugly head which is it actually
allows Studios to take bigger chunks of
your most successful movies and set it
to a provision for future bad movies and
this may explain all those Eddie Murphy
movies that would get rushed out at the
end of every year we have a big
provision built up so we got to write
off you know couple hundred M let's make
three bad
movies it's a provision that's being
built up it's completely arbitrary right
so let me ask you a question did
Paramount actually make money in Forest
gum
absolutely is this fair to Winston groom
depends on your death definition of the
word fair in fact he sued didn't last
very long got in front of a court and
the judge said Mr groom did you sign
this contract he said yes did you put
your fate in the hands of accountants I
said I guess so you got what you
deserved just to give you a contracts
you know what Steven Spielberg's
contracts were written as a percentage
of gate
receipts so you go into a New York movie
theater you pay $22 stepen is right
behind the Casher saying I'll take my 5%
now please cuz he's seen what'll happen
once the accountant start expensing
allocating
advertising it's a process that you may
be able to get an indirect benefit from
because I have 12 books with four
different Publishers and what I say
about any one of them I could say about
the other three they all screw me
over every one of my contracts looks
great how many of you have my apply
Corporate Finance
book see nobody did because it's obscene
you you do Derek you must be flush with
cash
then did it cost you what what did it
cost
you really it's that discounted now soon
it'll be on that Bargain Basement table
on the street right it was priced at
$100 when it first came out obscenely
overpriced but the contract specified
I'd make 15% of the net proceed s on
this book the accountant invented the
word net should be hung from a
tree right you're saying $100 15 I'm
making 15 I made 15 15% of 40 it's still
$6
right here an exercise I go through
every six months I get this report from
a publisher telling me how many books I
sold and how much my total royalty is so
I take this total royalty divide by the
number of books to see how close close
to 10 or $15 again you know the most
time made per book is
$150 I'm not asking for sympathy but
there's many a slip between the gross
and the net here
right so the first couple of years I got
this I would go through the statement to
see what
happened and one of the light items that
always stub me is in the end of the year
adjustment where half my royalties were
just
disappear what's happening here the end
of the year came up unexpectedly
and then what exactly you do throw half
my books into the Hudson so I called the
publisher of at the time and said you
know what I'd like to talk to somebody
about this line item I don't understand
what's going on they put me in touch
with the legal
department and if you spend 30 minutes
talking to a lawyer after the 30 minutes
you're apologizing for calling him say I
don't even know why I called you in the
first place so this lawyer and you know
he has a job to do takes me through it's
Clause seven see of the contract it's a
50-page contract I get to the clause and
I read I have no idea what it's telling
me there's a mention of an end of the
year there's a mention of an adjustment
how that became 50% of my royalties I
don't know so I hung up the phone while
the lawyer was going through this extend
because I wasn't getting anywhere and I
plotted my Petty
Revenge here's how I write my books I
write a chapter at a time a bing on
sequencing and as I write each chapter I
create a pdf version that I put online
ostensibly to get people to error check
it and give me feedback so my valuation
investment valuation book the fourth
edition that came out I think it's 34
chapters took the bulk of last year so I
put the PDF chapter one chapter 2
chapter 3 chapter 4 chapter 34 I'm done
with the book I get the feedback I send
the entire manuscript to the publisher
they published the book I forget to take
the PDF
files off I remember the first time it
happened I get this call from my
publisher saying what the hell are you
doing I knew exactly what he was calling
about but I decided to act innocent I
said you seem upset what seems to be
bothering you and she he said you put
your entire book
online I said so said you're going to
lose royalties I said what do I care I
make a $150 a book if I made $15 I might
care more he hasn't called me back since
so no so every one of my books is
actually somewhere on my web web page
the problem is I can't say investment
valuation fourth edition so for a brief
time I was using Mexican menu items to
describe a book enchilada Corporate
Finance book could download no burrito
another book would download and I'd say
know this is plausible deniability I
said I know how that happened no so if
you click around enough on my web page
all my books are there so Derek paid $40
you might get there by clicking on I I I
keep keep having to change it because
every time the publisher notices I have
to change it to a different so it's
somewhere there it'll take you a while
to get there but you want to save some
money you can get
there earnings versus cash flows 15% off
so you can see how quickly the cash flow
and the earnings numbers can diverge
second we're going to talk about the
notion of incremental cash flows when
you judge a project you should judge it
based on what it adds or takes away from
the firm that's a notion of incremental
for the moment again it sounds abstract
but I'll give you specific examples of
incremental and non-incremental items
and finally you want a Time weight the
cash flows sounds like it's something
fancy right the old Finance books at the
end of every book there'd be time value
tables because you didn't have
calculator easily available so it'll
tell you how much a dollar was worth in
one year 2 years 3 years 4 years 5 years
6 years so time so basically a dollar
next year is worth 91 cents but a dollar
15 years from now is worth only 35 cents
that's time waiting discounting cash
flows is time waiting a good measure of
a of return on a project will be time
weighted incremental cash flow return so
as I go through looking at projects I'm
going to give you different ways in
which companies assess returns and you
can make a judgment as to whether it's
getting close to what you'd like to see
so when I talk about projects people
often think about small projects to me
everything that companies do that invest
money is a project it could be a major
strategic decision if there's no money
behind your strategic decision it's all
anyway but if it's a strategic
decision and you're spending money it's
a big investment an acquisition is a
gigantic project a decision on a new
venture to enter into a lot of companies
are talking about creating an AI Venture
project it could be decisions where you
take existing projects and change the
way they run maybe you're you have a
retail arm and you want to try lower
inventory and more online selling still
a project even a decision to to put a
something in your offices to be maybe a
cappuccino maker you know on every floor
it's a project it's really small project
you might be doing it because you want
your people to hang around till midnight
every night the only way you can do it
is by feeding them caffeine all through
the day you of ulterior motive
everything companies do small or large
cost saving or Revenue generating fall
under the rubric of projects so here's
what I'd like to do I would like to take
a bunch of hypothetical
projects I mean you're saying why
everything else in the class we've
stayed with real numbers are you going
with hypothetical numbers and projects
why do you think that
is because to get project numbers you
got to be inside a company this is one
of the few aspects of corporate finance
where I can't look at but I do I'm going
to base each of these projects and
projects I observe on the outside so
we're going to do a Disney theme
park but the way I'm going to build up
to it is I can observe existence so it's
not it's like a docu drama which
basically is I'm writing a story but
built on something real so I'm going to
do a real Disney I would considered
karacus Disney but that might be a
little too far a bridge to cross so this
is a you know couple of theme parks that
Disney's planning to build in Rio so
we're going to talk about it'll allow us
to talk about what do you do when you
have projects in a foreign market in a
different currency and there's country
risk in there we're also going to talk
about a very different kind of
investment for Disney any of you
watching the Daredevil the new Daredevil
that's come
out so I have lots of time on my hand I
don't have to prepare for quizzes or
work on cases daredevil on Netflix was
my favorite show it's lasted Four
Seasons so it's come back again on
Disney great show but you know how much
each episode cost Disney to make about
$35 million a piece so we have eight
episodes this is like a gigantic big
budget
movie so the question is when you're a
streaming company how do you assess
whether a movie is good or not and we'll
talk about the challenges you
face what's the biggest challenge when
you're a streaming company trying to
decide
content what do we need
yeah there's no gate receipts no cash
flows no ratings night it's not like the
old days so why do you
make these
movies because two things one is push-up
subscriber count but remember the other
thing is new story just came out last
week that Disney now has the
stickiest subscriber base stickier than
Netflix higher you know renewal rates 97
98% that those Bluey
episodes It's that because they started
that as a side a if you ever watch the
bluey shows you should you should it's
actually fun lots of big lessons you
learn from them right that alone I think
accounts for a big chunk of the
stickiness you have a four-year-old on
Bluey there's no way you're canceling
your Disney subscription without your
four-year-old freaking out it's both the
numbers and the stickiness and already
you can see why that's going to be
difficult to assess right I've got to
convert that into cash flows we'll talk
about those challenges I also want to
talk about a new iron or mine for Val
very different kind of investment old
economy and it's going to be in Canada
why because you got to go where the iron
or is so they're a Brazilian iron or
mining company but they're the they're
the largest iron or Miner in on the face
of the Earth and so I'm going to talk
about how do you assess of M third I'm
going to talk about and this might
already be dated bookscape then was a
physical
bookstore know they wanted to create an
online retail arm because everybody else
was jumping on that bandwagon how would
you assess that and finally I'm going to
close off but by creating and this is a
completely hypothetical acquisition the
T motors which is an automobile
company would buy Harmon audio heard of
Harmon's legendary name and speakers and
music you saying why would a car company
go out and buy music because if you get
into a Tesla or a new car you notice the
sound system is a big part of the
package it's not just a sound system you
got a TV the size of the TV you have at
home it's only a matter of time before
Tesla puts a 70h TV in there and says
Don't drive just get in the car watch
the TV right the audio and the video
systems are becoming a big part so
they're buying this to get that into
their cars so we're going to talk about
how do you deal with the crossb
acquisition very different Investments
so let's start with the Disney team Park
in
before I embark on this I want to ask a
question I don't want you to feel
embarrassed about answering the question
so if you don't feel like answering the
question don't how many of you have
never been in a Disney theme
park okay you know how they used to make
Super Bowl
ads know and Eli Manning I'm going to go
to the last time the Giants were in the
Super Bowl which is so long ago it's
feels ancient Eli Man Manning you won a
Super Bowl where are you going to go
next there's a dis Disney so at the end
of this class we're going to make a
commercial with all of you who've never
been to a Disney theme par and now that
you're done with corporate finance what
are you going to do next I'm not going
to take an internship I'm going to go to
Disneyland right but even if you have
never been in a Disney theme park you
kind of know how it's structured
right every Disney theme park is
anchored around the Magic
Kingdom and every Magic Kingdom has a
castle that you walk through we could do
it in a trivia exercise in who Castle
cuz it's actually a different princess's
castle in each one so Disneyland is
Sleeping Beauty Euro Disney is Bell so
each so you walk through it's a fake
Castle but that goes without saying it's
a Disney theme park you walk through
you're in the happiest place on Earth
this is not my characterization this is
how Disney describes itself you're
surrounded by parents drag in screaming
kids around you but it's the happiest
place on Earth but that first
circle is where Disney Magic Kingdom
begins right you got all the little kids
right so and right in front of you
there'll be the Dumbo ride with a long
line in front of it every Disney theme
park is built around that same structure
so the Rio Disney is going to have a
Magic
Kingdom I don't know whose Castle it'll
be that'll be up for grabs
right and then you got the magic a
kingdom with all of the things directed
primarily at younger kids right
basically you know you get to visit
Mickey and Minnie and all the characters
the second theme park that Disney is
planning to build is structured to look
like Epcot have any of you been to Epcot
how many of you been to Epcot it's a
terrifying place if you think about it
right you walk in and the center the the
the heart of Epcot is an artificial leg
but again as I said everything about
Disney so surrounded by the whole world
so this is for people who don't like to
travel but want to see the
world in Epcot so each country gets a
building we'll talk about some
exceptions that I've never quite
understood how did that country not make
it and usually there's a restaurant that
goes with every building so you can eat
your way around the world it'll take you
about 3 hours this way you never have to
get a plane or a passport if you get all
the
way the country that you know you walk
around you you say Bulgaria didn't make
it I understand small country it slipped
under the radar you know I went the
first time I went I went three times I
must have missed it I must have missed
it you know who's not in that
country India is not there how do you
miss a billion people you know but
that's something that the next Epcot
might fix right so it's you know and the
Indian restaurant probably would get
much better people than the they have a
Finnish restaurant or Scandinavian
restaurant you go and you get fish on
top of
everything so two big theme parks is it
going to take a while to build these
theme parks
yeah so I'm going to start by cheating
and giving you the numbers entirely in
US Dollars why is that cheating because
these theme parks are in R the cash
flows are going to be in re
eyes why am I doing it in dollars
because you're going to play the role of
decision makers at Disney I'm going to
be a number
cruncher and I'm going to come back with
numbers say would you take this thing
Park so you have only one role in this
session the next couple is to be the
decision Mak based on the numbers I feed
you and because your decision makers
will tend to be in Burbank they work in
dollars my guess is you're going to be
more familiar with the dollar number
later in this process I'm going to ask
the question if I done everything in re
would my answer have been different
we'll see what the answer to that is but
let's so let me start by giving you the
information about these them pars the
first Magic Kingdom will cost three
billion to build you got to spend it
right now whenever you look at
investment descriptions you got to look
at timing because you know the cash
flows matter you got to spend two
billion right now and a billion a year
from now and it's going to be open for
operations at the start of year
three Epcot is going to cost a billion
and a half with a billion spent at the
end of the second year a half a billion
at the end of the third year and it's
not going to be open till the fourth
year so already you can see the opening
of these theme parks is going to get
staggered out now Disney's The Magic
Kingdom is going to come on in year two
EP card is going to come on in year four
why because timing
matters the Investments you're making
and collectively you're investing 3 plus
1 and a half billion 4 and A2
billion it's going to be treated as
Capital
expense this is not something you often
choose it's based on the tax rules and
this is a capital expense which means
that you will not get to expense them
while you spend it but you will get to
depreciate it over time and I'm going to
give you the depreciation
schedule so now comes the point where
the rubber has to meet the road let's
say you are the number cruncher you've
just been hired out of Pomona College
you're working at Burbank your managing
director or your boss comes in and says
we're thinking about this Rio theme park
and I'd like you to come up with the
expected revenues on this theme park and
the expenses on those
revenues you're staring at a blank
spreadsheet right so help me out here
when I have to estimate the revenues for
Rio Disney theme park what do you think
I'm going to start
with it's more obvious Place Kelly what
do you
think exactly start with the theme parks
it's not that they're going to replicate
but you at least have a sense right so
because these theme parks take a while
to build up then so I look at Orlando I
look at Tokyo I look at Euro Disney I I
know I didn't have shangai Disney then
but I'd look and I'd look to see it so
based on what I see there and adjusting
for the fact that this is Latin America
so you're looking at a very different
total Market I projected the revenues
along the way I have determined what I'm
going to charge as ticket prices I might
not be able to charge the $150 a day
they charge in Anaheim because in let
you might be able to get only 80 so I
take ticket prices so it's work but it's
work based on you already can see why
doing investment analysis much more
difficult if it's a first time
project when um Disney plus was started
huge upfront investment based on what
what do you think Disney based how much
I mean no if you look if you look back
at uh Bob chuk investing what billions
of dollars and you were the analyst
trying to estimate the cash flows what
did you probably look at the only thing
you could have looked at to make that
estiment nothing Disney did had that you
probably looked at Netflix and you hoped
and prayed that your numbers would look
like Netflix numbers right cuz if you
got numbers like Max you were not going
to make it you spending too much so my
point is we're making estimates we're
going to be wrong in hindsight we're
talk about how to deal with that
uncertainty so that's how I got the
revenues so you notice that there's no
revenues in year one for Magic Kingdom
why because I'm still building the theme
park I could have been creative and
charge people to come and watch the
construction in the world we live in who
knows people would have paid for that as
well but I wasn't creative enough so
basically Revenue start in year two and
for EP got they start and so that
reflects my judgment on revenues the
total revenues as you can see for those
two theme parks build up over time
you're saying what's that third column
Resort properties if you've been to
Orlando you got Disney World but Disney
World is actually like 8 miles away from
everything in Orlando you got to drive
and drive and drive to get there which
means you got to get up at 6:00 in the
morning with three kids who are
incredibly grumpy put them in a car
drive 8 Miles if you want to avoid that
Disney offers you a solution right it's
an expensive solution you can stay on
site technically you still have to drive
but only two miles there are Disney
properties around you stay at the
Contemporary you don't even have to get
in a car you get get down from your room
you can catch the the the train that
runs right into Disney but you pay I
think I checked yesterday $800 per per
night right now which is off seon with
the Contemporary so these are basically
properties that derive their value from
the theme parks because nobody goes and
stays at the swan or the Contemporary no
big know Orlando theme unless you have
want to go to Disney this is really
pointless if you're going to go
somewhere else in Orlando to stay there
so those revenues are very closely tied
to how many people come to the theme
parks and based on what I saw in Orlando
which was the best you know proxy for
what I wanted here for every dollar I
make in revenues of theme parks I get
about 25 cents so this is basically tied
to my gate receipts so nobody's coming
to my theme parks nobody's coming to my
Resorts as well you add the three
numbers up you get the revenues they
started 1.25 billion and they built up
to about 4.7 billion remember you're the
decision makers is it starting to look
good there's a lot of revenues right but
I haven't told you anything about the
expenses so let me give you what I
assumed about the expenses again based
on the existing theme parks if you look
at the existing theme parks the direct
cost of running the theme parks is about
60% what do I mean by direct
cost you're going to Disney team Park
are there an awful lot of employees
around you it's almost like they're
shadowing you the person picking up
stuff right behind you know as you drop
things even but you don't drop things
they seem to be picking up things a lot
of people and if you're in line there
are like 16 Disney employees going up
and down the line making sure you don't
cheat there are a lot of people to run
these theme parks once in a while a ride
breaks down there people maintenance
Crews so the direct cost is the cost of
actually running the theme park for
every dollar they collect in Revenue 60
cents goes into those costs and I'm
assuming that'll continue for the Rio
theme park and there I stopped and
thought about is that reasonable is the
cost going to be different in a and I I
decided wasn't but that's a judgment
call on the resort properties where they
make Revenue 75% goes into the direct
cost of maintaining those hotels and
properties so I put that 75 so now I
have direct expenses but there are two
other expenses I'm going to throw in
here which are not directly related to
people coming to the theme park one is
an allocation of what's called a GNA
cost this is a an item that bedevils
people right and if any of you work in a
company there's a GNA cost what goes
into that damn thing it's like billions
of dollars what goes into
GNA take the S out the S we can
understand selling cost but what the
heck is
GNA how many of you worked at large
companies before you came to school if
you worked at large companies there were
entire floors of people you had no idea
what they did what did they do I don't
know they come in they see work on floor
15 and then they go home there are
people in every company who are cost
centers but there's no revenue and that
includes the CEO right when is the last
time a CEO actually got revenues there a
cost and these are costs without
revenues and that drives accountant
crazy so you know what they do they take
these expenses they bundle them all
together they call it a GNA cost and
then they go looking looking for what
people with revenues so they can attach
the cost to you oh you have revenues
we'd like you to have 200 million in GNA
no I don't want that no you can have it
part of the family feeling it's an
allocation of expenses and if you're
doing a project often you see an
allocated expense in this case that
expense is going to be 15% of Revenue
somebody in Burbank has decided this is
the rule but I want to also add that 2/3
of these expenses have nothing to
do with the r theme park there's some
guy in Burbank and you're paying for for
the Rio theme park because the costs
have to go somewhere file that away
because it's going to become significant
in that incremental cash flow
question the other expenses remember
those big 4 and a half billion 5 billion
you invested to build the theme parks
that's going to get written off and
starting about 25 years ago in the US
these depreciation schedules are set by
the IRS so all those depreciation
methods you learn in your accounting
completely useless now because from a
tax perspective you don't get to pick
between some of the your double
declining there's a schedule you tell me
what asset you have I'll tell you the
life and how much you're writing off
there's the schedule of depreciation
each year so in year one your
depreciation is going to be 12 half% of
Book value because that's what the tax
laws
saying what's that second
column now depreciation you know if you
is an accounting number but it's also
capturing economic loss of value right
your rides are getting older they're
going to start to break down if it's an
8-year old ride it's going to break down
more do you need to spend money on
maintenance yes but you also have to
actually replace entire rids sometimes
if you go to a Disney theme park again
at least two or three of the rids are
under
construction I call this Capital
maintenance Capital maintenance is not
just maintaining but keep your theme
park looking fresh and new you
constantly have to renew it adding stuff
taking away stuff so that capex is tied
to depreciation why because depreciation
is what you're losing then I have to
make up for some of it to kind of keep
the theme park looking good and to keep
going there's a story I'm telling about
this project it's not going to end in
your 10 it's going to keep going and if
I want to do that he's saying why is it
lower up front because your rides it's
still new things are not breaking down
yet as you get further and further in it
starts to catch up with depreciation
could even exceed depreciation if
there's inflation so that's the capital
maintenance and finally there are two
other assumptions I'm going to make
first is that there will be non-cash
working capital it's not a big deal but
there's essentially the equivalent of
inventory receivables but that will
affect my cash flows and it's going to
be 5% of revenues
whenever you're working capital it'll
usually be tied either to
revenues things like receivables or to
cost a good sold things like payables
and inventory because you got to tie it
to one of the top lines because when you
change those you want those numbers to
change as
well remember the marginal tax rate of
36.1% I'm going to keep it here why you
saying why are you using a marginal tax
rate because this theme park will create
earnings on the margin L on to existing
earnings
so I'm going to play accountant for a
few minutes my accounting is a little
rusty so Kelly will correct me if I'm
wrong is there any other accountant I
don't want to keep picking on okay two
accountants in the room you'll keep me
honest right so first I want to keep
track of how accountants think of how
much is invested in a project they use
Book value right what goes into Book
value your Capital
expenditures what goes out of Book value
every time you depreciate that goes out
of Book value and I'm going to include
working capital as part of that book
value because after all it is an asset
as well so each year what you see here
is my capex showing up as part of my
book value depreciation reducing that
book value and the working capital that
I have to maintain going into so I'm
going to call this the invested capital
in this project I'm going to call it
invested Capital because according to
the accountant that's what I've invested
and you can see that the invested
capital in this project builds up as I
keep adding it starts to decrease but it
levels off you know in most projects
invested Capital will start to get
written off very quickly so it'll Peak
and then you know why it's not dropping
off the cliff what is it about my
assumptions that's preventing invested
capital from just shrinking as you go
get
older invested Capital decrease because
you have depreciation right so if I just
depreciate and I don't put any money
back into the project my invested
capital is going to fall off because I'm
putting a big chunk of my depreciation
back into the project my invested
Capital stays intact there is a reason
you need to do that and it's tied to
what you assume about what happens after
your attemp so you're going to see me
complete that Loop so you have to
estimate cash flows based on what you
think the project will do for you as a
company so I'm at least going to get
started on the earnings part of this
project remember I'm wearing my
accounting hat accountants think the
bottom line is earnings I'm going to to
stay with that fiction so to get to the
earnings on this theme park I'm going to
start with revenues and I gave you the
assumptions there right nothing in year
one but then it builds up starting in
year two the expenses there are my
direct expenses each year and I also
subtract out depreciation and allocated
GNA I think like an accountant I'm not
questioning whether the GNA is
incremental or not I'm just subtracting
out the allocated expense I come up with
the operating income
you're saying warant you subtracting
interest expenses we'll talk about it
I'm going to compute earnings without
looking at interest
expenses you look at the operating
income in year one I have minus 50
million if you ask me why I'm losing
money the answer is easy I I'm spending
money but the theme park hasn't
opened so I have a loss in your one
right you notice I have a minus 18 in
taxes you're saying what does it even
mean I'm actually building in a tax
saving of 18 million I'm going to get
because of this
loss anybody want to guess why how I'm
getting away doing this I mean obviously
the RS doesn't mail me a check for 18
million but what is it about this
project and what you know about Disney
as a company that allows me Patrick what
what do you think I'm assuming in your
one that allows me to claim the tax
benefit one is remember Disney doesn't
file taxes for individual projects it
files taxes as a company right it makes
billions of dollars so when you have a
money losing project you don't wait till
future years to get the tax saving you
get it this year if this were a
standalone project I couldn't do this
because there I to track the losses
carry my n forward here I'm getting the
tax savings right away so there's my
after tax operating income it does it is
negative till year three and then
finally it turns
positive so 421 Million by the time I
get year 10 decision makers
said that's a lot of money
right is that enough for you to tell me
to take the project what have I what do
you not know yet now what what would you
like me to do with the 421 million
that'll make your decision
easier and to do that I've got to
convert the 421 million into a
percentage return right dollar returns
don't help and now you see why had that
lead and on the previous page I gave you
the invested Capal according to the
accountants if I take the after tax
operating income and divide by the
invested Capital I'm staying in the
accounting Universe I come up with
what's called a return on invested
Capital this legendary number that
people throw on this is all it is after
tax operating income divided by invested
capital and not surprisingly the number
starts negative and it builds up over
time as my earnings improve so if you
look at the numbers individually you
look at year nine I
so you're a decision maker you're saying
what do I do if I have 10 different
numbers so what's the logical thing to
do when the numbers change take the
average so here's my last question I
want you to think about because we'll
start the next class with this question
the return on Capital I'm getting on
this project staying in the accounting
universe is
4.11% I need a hurdle rate to compare it
to I'll give you the choices and I want
you to think about these choices we'll
start the next class with what choice I
could use the risk fre rate as my hurdle
rate it beats at
2.75% I could give you the cost of
equity for Disney as a company the cost
of caps for Disney as a company the cost
of equity for Disney's theme parks that
should be cost so basically cost of
equity or cost of capital theme park or
company or just go with the risk free
rate I think you can reason your way to
An Answer given what we've already
talked about but next class when we
start we'll start with which of those
numbers would I compare compar it to
because the only number 4.11 beats is
2.75% but I want to say cost of equity
or cost of capital from or team par